hi there here i am again steve talking
about languages talking about my korean
challenge
and uh by the way if you enjoy these
podcasts please uh subscribe
and today i want to talk about this
issue of you know fluency
becoming fluent versus this sort of
intermediate level that i said the other
day was was a very valid level to
achieve in a language
so how do i sort of reconcile the fact
that i i strive for fluency uh you know
that's what i want to achieve i don't
want to just be able to say hello how
are you my name is i actually want to
get to this level of fluency and yet i'm
happy to be
call it mediocre in some of my languages
so what
there would almost appear to be a
contradiction here so let me explain
further
uh how i feel on this to me i think
fluency is b2 on the european scale so
for those of you who don't know there's
six levels b2 is the fourth level i
think five and six or c1 and c2 are sort
of mastery okay that fluency is
something less and fluency can be
sort of
because we have speaking and writing and
listening and reading so
you can be at that b2 level you can even
be a c1 level in terms of reading let's
say
or some people are the other way around
they speak better so that doesn't mean
that we're equally strong in all aspects
of our language skills but typically i
find that if i have very good say
listening and comprehension skills even
if my speaking skills are not so good if
i get
enough of an opportunity to use the
language my speaking skills will catch
up so if we have the right attitude and
put in the time if we can be ahead in
some skills and if we put more effort
into those other skills they'll come
back up to that level
so
i think that
and from that point of view if i have
let's say b2 skills
in
i don't know like oh i'll give you an
example i went out with uh with my wife
and my son and daughter-in-law
and and one of our grandchildren we went
to dinner and seated beside us was these
two couples and they were speaking
polish and i was just delighted to hear
polish i haven't heard live people face
to face sort of people speaking polish
so of course i tried to tell them that i
had studied polish and of course i could
understand what they were saying but i
was totally tongue-tied couldn't say a
thing because i've been focusing on
korean
but i still consider myself to be kind
of a weak intermediate in polish at
least potentially because if i had even
a day of speaking polish my polish could
come up however
you know all the effort that i put into
polish listening and reading and the
conversations on skype all of that i'm
very happy with and it doesn't bother me
that my attempt to save very much was
ended up in failure it doesn't bother me
at all because potentially i know that i
can improve so my goal is to achieve
this fluency this ability not only to
listen and read but also eventually to
speak
in the language at a b2 level
but when i do that for example russian
uh i recently did a video on russian
here and i hadn't been speaking russian
and so people quickly pointed out that
gee you know your uh
your uh you know uh endings are worse
than they were before and stuff well
that's fine i don't mind that uh and
then maybe if i speak a while they'll
get better so so that's kind of my take
on that so i'm never i'm not a
perfectionist like in japanese people
talk about pitch in japanese
i don't even know what they're talking
about i've never even heard it i
communicate fine i did a video and i
said watakshiwa and people told me no
one says about takeshi someone said you
know i know i don't have to you know
listen to this guy because he says well
takshi instead of watashi when i lived
in japan i think i heard watakshi more
than watashi maybe not so it's watashi
it doesn't matter all these little
things
what was it they talk about in russian
something about
palliative
consonants or something i don't even
know what they're talking about
i think when i started speaking russian
again i think
gabardic i think i said more like
gabaric as in polish rather than gabaric
because i had been listening or had been
doing a lot of polish doesn't matter
to me
so that my goal is fluency i won't
achieve mastery i'll achieve sort of the
ability to understand a lot and the
ability to communicate effectively when
given enough opportunity to do so
that's sufficient
and so
that's intermediate in my opinion now
obviously if you're working in the
language if i were living in
poland and had to work there and had to
send out letters in polish that
represented my company then i would have
to achieve a much higher level but
for me in terms of
what i need from these languages this
mediocre call it intermediate a lot
plenty of mistakes understand can
communicate
if given enough opportunity to get
warmed up that's good enough
so i hope that clarifies the possible
contradictions between sort of
intermediate and fluency
and look forward to your comments as
usual and don't forget to subscribe bye
for now